tyree keys the victory
one get tariq the ball
two get tariq the ball
three nah nah i'm not i'm not even gonna
say that i just run fast man even if
they double me i just run faster you
know because that's
because if they double me and i'm
running fast that's going to clear
somebody else up
tyree kill as fast as they come in the
national football league and that's a
simple key to victory get the ball to
the fastest guy on the field not scottie
miller tyree kill and i i still marvel
at the highlights from the afc
championship
when you see
nfl caliber defensive backs get twisted
around by that speed that burst and that
suddenness of tyreek hill
to be that much better at that level is
incredible shireen
you know i i the best catch i think he
made was the one that didn't count i
can't remember what that game was i
think it was a monday night game right
or a sunday night game where he made the
catch on his hip and they didn't know to
review it he didn't even know he caught
the ball but some of the catches he
makes are just amazing it's not just the
speed but the catches he makes
are outstanding and he ranks right up
there i can't imagine trying to stop him
and travis kelsey both it's an
impossible task
well the bills were able to stop neither
that's the problem you could ideally
take away one the bills were able to
take away neither and it really makes me
wonder what the buccaneers are gonna
have figured out i hope for their sake
they won't do the single coverage of
tyreek hill he was on pace based on the
first half of the first quarter of that
week 12 game to have a thousand yards in
the game patrick holmes at halftime had
369
or 359 passing yards
and so that had him on pace to set the
single game record the buccaneers did
something down the stretch to figure it
out whatever it was they did in the
second half they need to bottle it and
they need to use that shireen from the
get-go on sunday
absolutely and like we talked about mike
it's going to help if you have your
safeties in there you're starting
safeties and they jordan white had made
such big plays in that a nfc
championship game before he left they
really need those guys
to step up but that defense has got to
play better they've got to get pressure
on patrick mahomes whether they sack him
or not is a different thing but at least
pressure him a little bit and do it
without blitzing because we know how
good patrick mahomes is against the
blitz mike
yeah and uh it's against the blitz it's
against any pressure whatsoever the big
question though is
what can that offensive line do to slow
down the guys who may get a chance to
get after patrick holmes but he is so
slippery and you know something von
miller told us last year something
robert sala told us last week that
ability to just backpedal you know when
you've got that baseball player
shortstop arm where you don't have to
have a good base and a good foundation
and all the mechanical things that allow
a quarterback to to crack that ball down
the field you can just make the throw
falling over backward that that makes
you even more dangerous when you're
trying to elude the rush because you
can't take those steps backwards you
can't fade backward and still make that
that incredible throw
with just your arm and that's where we
might see the toe being better this week
mike having gone three weeks now with
the chance for it to recover and in the
afc championship game he did have only
five carries for five yards so we might
see him more as a runner in this game
if that toe truly is a hundred percent
or close to 100 percent than we did in
the afc championship game because we
know what he can do with his legs we've
seen it in the pocket or out of the
pocket he can move mike when he's at 100
and you know the one memory that sticks
out for me this season the game against
the dolphins
when he got sacked for a 30-yard loss
that was the one rare occasion when he
always seems to know how it all fits
together right and he knows how he can
get away and he knows how much time he
has and then he told me after the game
he just took kind of a weird step at the
wrong time and he thought he was clear
and the next thing he knows he's down on
the ground that does not happen very
often with patrick mahomes last year the
49ers did sack him four times in the
super bowl but when it counted when he
had to buy time with his feet to let
tyreek hill get open 40 yards down the
field for that play that that was the
moment when we were like uh oh uh oh the
uh uh oh the the 49ers despite a
10-point lead and seven minutes left are
in trouble
he just he just
finds a way
in those moments tom brady tends to find
a way
in certain games
from our homes
it just can happen at any time it's like
you're you're searching in the dark for
that light switch and all of a sudden
when you almost are completely out of
hope he finds it and it's like it was
never off
yeah and he could take a big sack my and
the next thing you know you know it's
third and long or second long or
whatever it is and they managed to gain
the first down somehow some way so it
doesn't even matter but i do think the
bucks have to do a better job of getting
after him than they did in that first
meeting in week 12. you mentioned the
49ers had the four stacks in the super
bowl last year the bucks had two sacks
in that week 12 game shaq barrett had
one and jason pierre paul had won i
think shaq barrett and jason pierre paul
may be the biggest keys in this game
they've got to do more to get pressure
without the bucks having to blitz and
really forcing patrick mahomes to make
some quick throws so tyree kill doesn't
have time perhaps to get behind him
as we get closer to the game i have a
dilemma and i want your advice on
something and yes this is my way of
bragging that the blind squirrel is
chewing on an acorn i picked the
buccaneers to win the super bowl before
the season now i picked them to beat the
patriots
i didn't pick them to beat the chiefs
can i
now bail
on the buccaneers and pick the chiefs is
that
as a matter of game picking etiquette
would that be appropriate at this
juncture
yeah you know i think since the whole
season has passed i think you get a pass
on that and you would be allowed to pick
the chiefs at this so i picked the bucks
to get there and lose to the ravens so
i'm still okay with the bucks if if they
lose at least i can say i got the bucks
there and i picked them to lose in the
super bowl before the year started so
that's pretty good when you go one or
two but yeah i think you're allowed mike
in that instance to make a change on
your pick
okay so if i do pick the chiefs to win
the super bowl and the tampa bay
buccaneers win i can still say
i picked the buccaneers to win
the super at least one before the season
began
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports